i've been saying for some time don't get
me wrong there is a symbiotic
relationship
between china and the united states
china doesn't have enough food
and we don't have enough technology but
there's this point of friction in
between called taiwan
and so walk us through your next
prediction because this is
enormous i i look at huawei's got
huawei's got
a third of all telecommunications
equipment on the planet is in the hands
of
one company i mean you could say that
there is
a tangible national security threat
simply because of china's dominance
in the technology sphere but again
there's this thing in between
and the biggest semiconductor producer
in the world
happens to be right there in taiwan so
walk us through where you see this
headed
so i've written extensively and talked
extensively danielle about the idea that
this u.s
china rivalry is not just a trade
conflict it's not just
a tech race it's not just a space race
it's not just an arm tree
it's not just a currency war this is
full
spectrum great power rivalry
let's not call it anything else that's
what it is
um and so i think that's an important
context to think about
because when we get to this thing that
you
indicate wisely is between us this
little island
formosa or taiwan
we have provided de facto security
guarantees
to protect them we also
have signed in the shanghai communique
that there is one china
based in beijing and so
in theory we don't recognize this entity
that we're providing support
to um in theory we're going to protect
an entity that
is a portion of another sovereign state
and the chinese view this really uh
as as quite insulting right it's that uh
you know i actually met with uh some
some very senior chinese
political leaders uh last year and
the analogy used was well wait vikram
how would you feel if we
sold military equipment and arms to
california
i said well actually you don't
understand i'd be fine with that but i
said
he said no no i mean like if it was part
of your country i was like yeah i
understand i'm joking because
the californians think differently than
the rest of us
but they view it as arming
one of their states effectively to be
independent
and foreign countries supporting that
you know especially given the context of
the
sort of foreign powers carving up china
in you know the 1800s through the early
1900s this is a
problematic history they believe that
great rejuvenation of the chinese
uh nation state has been coming together
they've reclaimed
uh macau they've reclaimed hong kong
they're bringing back
the sort of territory and here's this
one thorn that
we their rival in a great power sense
continues to support i think it's the
it's got the potential to be a
flashpoint um
and i don't know what that flashpoint or
how that flashpoint actually comes
uh into into relief so to say but
is it conceivable i think the chinese
were trying very
much to diplomatically turn the
political tide
domestically within taiwan um i
shouldn't even use that word that's
that's an assumption to call it
domestically within taiwan
um to turn the tide
that you use the term domestically yes
well the idea being the chinese were
trying to get
a local sentiment in favor of
reintegration diplomatically
peacefully etc uh i think after their
crackdowns on hong kong the
taiwanese election went the other
direction and that resulted in
a resetting of strategic thinking around
how to reintegrate this wayward province
back to the motherland and america
stands in the way
so i think it's a flashpoint i think
it's a real potential problem it's
something to watch
closely we'll see uh you know
this could be a real test of of us
military resolve in the asia pacific
well the stakes are pretty high if you
consider how you started answering the
question
with a clash of two superpowers that's
right
[Music]
you